each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so it's my pleasure to introduce Craig
Zyliss who's a professor at the
University of Illinois and that's been
there for almost six years
Craig reminded me that he overlapped
with me for a year at Wisconsin can't
say I remember Craig but he say hey he
has some good stories from from when I
was there and it's a pleasure to welcome
Craig he's gonna talk to us about
hardware/software co-designed a very
relevant topic these days thank you Jim
as you said my name is Craig Zyliss I'm
from the University of Illinois and I'm
going to talk about some of my work
today and of course this is work that I
did with a number of my students but it
all kind of fits into this under this
umbrella of hardware/software co.design
for general purpose processors so I'm
going to talk about three distinct
pieces of work today and by all means if
you have questions interrupt me at any
time and I'm happy to to address them
and I would love feedback and insults
and whatnot but I'm going to talk about
hardware support for facilitating
compiler optimization a better I think
hybrid transactional memory design and
harvard hardware support for arbitrary
profile collection and all those
relatively distinct things they all fall
into the same sort of theme of hardware
software code design so I'm going to
talk a little about that theme and sort
of the research process that we take to
to do this kind of work
so the first thing about hardware
software co.design is I'm not claiming
it's a new idea nor that I invented it
but what it is is that's recognizing
that hardware and software have distinct
strengths and that if you build systems
that are aware of those strengths you
can build systems that are better than
just building for example software on
top of existing hardware or hardware
underlying existing software and I'm
personally interested in the
general-purpose computing context and
that sort of boils down to finding out
what are the essential reusable
primitives and so an essential I mean
that you can't take anything more away
from them and still be able to build the
software systems that you want to build
and reusable in the sense that there
just specific to an application so
they're not accelerators they're useful
for multiple applications so again it's
not a new idea that historically the
notion of hardware software Co design
goes back as far as instruction set
design and to some extent instruction
set designs fallen out of favor as
people recently in the last 15 years or
so realized that they could do most of
the stuff that they wanted to do
completely microarchitecture early that
is without changing the interface
between hardware and software we could
add the mechanisms that we wanted for
the most part to get to improve
performance and whatnot but two things
have been changing recently which makes
looking at rethinking instruction set
and whatnot more interesting the first
being that power is increasingly
becoming the primary design constraint
in that we could do everything in
hardware but it's probably not the most
efficient way to do it and so the
multi-core trend is a big visible sign
of this but more generally we're
rethinking how to do things more
efficiently secondly there's a trend
towards people writing software for
richer runtime environments for example
the Java Virtual Machine or Microsoft's
net and in those systems we already have
this kind of hardware software layer
running underneath applications and so
it lowers the barrier to rethinking the
boundary between the hardware and
software components that we already have
there so the the idea of hardware
software co.design again is to to draw
on these complementary strengths and
thing i want to point out is in fact
that they are complementary one of the
big strengths of hardware is that you
can add new parallel circuits that allow
you to do things add new functionality
with very little or no overhead in some
cases and this address is one of the
main weaknesses of software that often
to add new functionality you have to add
overhead in addition hardware is very
dynamic in that it can do small grain
fine grain decision making at runtime
based on
application behavior and based on the
the current machine context based on
what resources are available and this
addresses another potential weakness of
software which is the rate that it can
adapt to changing application behavior
but hardware has its own weaknesses for
example we're not able to dedicate very
much storage to retaining this kind of
contextual information and so we only
get a very small picture of what's going
on in the application whereas software
has the ability to do analysis and
optimizations that have scope and effort
that's effectively only limited by the
amount of resources that we want to
dynamically allocate to them furthermore
most of the optimizations that Hardware
comply are tend to be transient in that
we might learn something about program
behavior but as we move on to another
phase of the program we'll forget that
and so if we come back to the first
phase we're gonna have to relearn it
whereas software we can encode the
optimizations as part of the executable
either by transforming the executable
itself or annotating it somehow to carry
that information
finally hardware although it's very good
at recording information about what's
happened in the past has little
knowledge about what might happen in the
future
whereas software has the ability to do
analysis which is sound and do things
like realize that there's some
operations that just won't need to be
executed which is something that
Hardware effectively can't do so what
hardware software code design again is
is is understanding the limitations of
hardware and software and building
systems that address the limitations of
hardware with software and vice versa
and so really what we do in this process
is thinking about what can't we do with
existing hardware interfaces what is
frequently done versus what can be done
only once or statically how little
hardware can I require and still get the
system that I want and to what degree
can the hardware we include be
generalized for multiple uses and really
sort of boils down to thinking what are
the right primitives that if I provide
these primitives it'll enable us to
build more interesting software systems
or better performance or better
reliability
you're better efficiency or whatnot and
the key challenge of doing this is that
you need to understand both the hardware
and the software very well and so that
leads to this methodology of identifying
a problem area or opportunity
identifying a candidate primitive for
that problem or opportunity and then
actually building the software system on
top of it and at that point you can
evaluate the system as a whole and most
importantly you can go back and revisit
the primitive and scrutinize to what
degree you got it right and you know
what what more you might need to add or
what you can take away that you can try
to understand what are the true
requirements and so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna walk through each of these
three pieces of work then I'm gonna tell
you about and try to tell you what we
learned from taking this research
methodology so again the first thing
that I'm going to look at is hardware
support for simplifying the
implementation of compiler optimizations
and this is work that we had in last
year's iske and was also selected as one
of 10 papers for the I Triple E micros
top picks in computer architecture so
the idea here is well a lot of
architecture techniques either improve
performance or reduce power compiler
optimizations can do both that they can
improve performance by reducing the
number of instructions on the program's
critical path as well as reduce power by
reducing the number of dynamic
instructions executed and so it's a
great lever for efficiency and so the
question we asked ourselves was what
could the hardware do that would
facilitate compiler optimization so our
goal was to reduce the optimization
implementation complexity simplify
implementing the optimizations therefore
more compilers would implement them and
even the ones that were already
implementing these kinds of
optimizations might implement them more
aggressively and get more opportunity
and the the key notion was that the need
to verify compiler optimization is one
of the things that limits its
aggressiveness for example there is a
number of optimizations that
been you know done in research but I
haven't actually made it into production
compilers because of this verification
challenge and this work specifically
focuses on speculative compiler
optimizations so the primitive we looked
at was atomic execution basically the
hardware giving us the ability to
execute a region of code completely and
have it appear that it executed
instantly or not execute at all and so
to interface to the hardware we expose
three instructions that serve as markers
for the boundaries of this atomic
execution the first is a region begin
instruction which says okay this is the
beginning of the atomic region I want to
execute a region end instruction that
says go ahead and if you get to this
point commit this instruction you can
commit all of the instructions in
between and a region abort instruction
which if this instruction gets committed
it causes the whole region to roll back
to the region begin instruction restore
the state as of that instruction and
transfer control to this alternate PC
and what this lets us do is it allows
the compiler to generate code ignoring
all the uncommon cases that are that the
application could do but don't happen in
practice so for example if we have a
particularly hot path through the code
as indicated by the red code but there's
an exit from this hot cat path to this
cold code what we can do is we can wrap
the whole thing in this atomic region
and transform this branch into a piece
of code that asserts that the fall
through case is what's actually going to
get executed and that lets the compiler
ignore this code completely for the
purpose of optimizing the hot path so
that's the key thing we're enabling in
and branches are one example but there
are other cases that we can also exclude
by using these kind of insertions so
what we do this with this we've done
this in the context of a java virtual
machine where it fits very naturally but
we're going to collect some profile
information that allows us to identify
the hot parts of the
code and so we go and we optimize those
code those parts of the code and we
generate a hot version of our fast
version of the code which handles those
particular hot cases but maybe not all
the other ones so this might be
sufficient for handling 99% of the code
and we're going to replace all the
things that don't happen in practice
with checks to verify that in fact that
they aren't happening in addition we're
going to generate a general version of
the code and non-speculative version of
the code that's going to handle those
rare cases where the optimized version
of the code doesn't actually apply and
so what this lets us do is take a very
complicated piece of code and where it
has a relatively simple version this is
what happens in practice whereas
traditional speculative optimizations
without hardware support has to handle
potential exits from this hot path back
to the the non speculative code and this
this places two constraints on the
compiler one is these hot these exits
from the hot path can potentially limit
the degree we can optimize the hot path
and in addition we have to correctly
generate any fix-up code necessary from
for converting the state from this hot
code to the the the cold code and
getting that right in practice can be
challenging and so what the atomic
regions do is they greatly simplify this
process because all of those things all
those potential exits from the hot path
get converted into these abort
statements which then roll the whole
region back to the beginning and at that
point we can transfer control to this
code and so there's really only one exit
from the hot code that we have to worry
about and that's at the very beginning
before we've changed any state and so
that case can be handled trivially and
what that means is we can take this
piece of code that originally had a
hundred exits from the hot path and we
can reduce it down to a much simpler
piece of of control flow that only has
five basic blocks and two branches and
having done that we can
why existing traditional formulations of
optimizations and they're now able to
get the speculative optimization
potential or at least a bunch of it in
this code region question a check that
specifically checks to see whether that
aliasing there they are not aliasing in
which case then we can assume that they
are for the for the whole region does
that make sense so you're right there's
potentially if I have to worry about all
the the potential interactions that's
not something that we've heavily
exploited there's potentially other
Hardware mechanisms that would be more
efficient for detecting whether various
variables alias my guess is that you can
get a bunch of the potential without
having to do the full cross-product of
that but I'm not willing to guarantee
that that's the case is there more that
you wanted to follow up on or so that's
the that's the the goal of what we're
doing
I'll talk a little more about the the
hardware primitive again we have exposed
these three instructions and what
they're doing is the atomic begin is
taking a register checkpoint we're
actually doing that in a more efficient
way assuming an out-of-order machine by
checkpointing the register rename table
but that's just a hack to get this to be
lower overhead in addition we want to
make sure all future memory operations
are speculative we want to be able to
rollback stores in particular and so we
do that by adding speculative read and
write bits to each cache line and this
is a pretty standard trick in the
architecture community which has been
you
for thread level speculation speculative
la collision and Hardware transactional
memories assuming we get to an atomic
ending we can commit that instruction at
that point we have we will commit the
whole atomic region in which case we can
discard the register rename table Check
Point commit all the speculative memory
operations basically doing a flash clear
on all these bits and those those values
become visible and the whole regions
committed or if we commit an atomic
abort instruction then we restore the
rename table checkpoint with that
alternate PC and we're going to discard
all the speculative memory rights so
basically any bit any block in the cache
that has this right bit set we're going
to invalidate and so we're thrown away
that speculative value and the key is or
one of the keys is that if in addition
we raise an implicit abort and do this
same process anytime we get a coherence
conflict we get Adam isset II out of
this so if another thread accesses a
line in the cache that we have read or
written and their coherence request
causes us to to downgrade such that we
can't retain read or write permission
then we abort ourself because somebody's
potentially trying to peek at one of our
variables while we're executing so by
doing that we guarantee atomicity also
which allows us to reorder operations
and not have to worry about thread
safety as long as we preserve a
uniprocessor ordering question the
speculative optimization application of
this do you thought about doing anything
special if the transaction of works for
capacity or conflict reasons as opposed
to an explicit abort for a test for the
conditions for staying on yeah so let me
answer this slide and then I'll get back
to your question or talk about the slide
and then I'll get back to your question
if I can
so what we're assuming in this hardware
is that it's best-effort that it's not
gonna guarantee that any particular
region of code is gonna make forward
progress and what that does is it
greatly simplifies implementing this
from the hardware designers perspective
that the hardware designer can decide
that we're going to abort this region
for any case that might be complicated
and so one obvious ones that would be
hard to implement is is handling i/o
atomically dealing with interrupts and
in particular limited buffering so we're
only going to support for example what
might fit in the l1 cache and not
propagate all these bits down to lower
levels of the cache and one of our
findings which is relatively you know I
think one more interesting findings is
that we can build compilers that are
very tolerant of this best-effort
atomicity that basically we try to
select regions that are either a cyclic
or are very likely to you know recycle a
short number of times such that they
will almost always fit within the
available buffering and so we - I guess
to get back to your question we try to
avoid that problem proactively by not
selecting regions that are going to
overflow the cache and I guess I can't
quantify to what degree we're
sacrificing performance by the the the
region selection that we are doing but I
guess we're able to get significant
performance in the presence of the
region selection that we're doing does
that address your question any other
questions yep all the memory operations
are going to appear - all of the threads
as if they happen all at the same time
reasons soft where are your reasons then
it won't be atomic what do you feel
about the risk that this might actually
cause people to write software that
instead of working right 99% of the time
works now 99.99% of the time because now
it has to go down the slow path and have
another it's very touching memory the
same time to fail so therefore you're
personally making software less robust
so it's it's an interesting question so
certainly Louis says he at the
University of Washington has a paper
that says if if you have an execution
model where they tend to chunk things
and commit them ik atomically it can
mask these race conditions under some at
some frequency so that's a paper that
he's presenting it it's good this summer
so certainly that effect would be
present you know I don't know what to
you know
comment to it that certainly it could be
a negative byproduct of this but I'm not
sure it's worth throwing out the baby
okay so certainly we and I'll talk about
this in the next section we assume that
we can know the reason why something
failed and therefore transfer over to
software to handle things differently so
when I talk about the transactional
memory system that is a very important
piece of that could be yeah
so that that's that if
effort because you've got now two paths
you have to explicitly test for
essentially so I guess so the the we
really aren't you know one of the
impressive things about this is we
didn't change the compiler much except
for region selection and I think that
that'll be in a couple slides later
so yes you you could imagine that we
have to some extent the same problem
that speculative compiler optimizations
have but less so so the problem with
respective pilot optimizations if I go
back to this slide is I have all of
these potential paths that I would need
to test and so I 64 this problem comes
up in spades
so yes we have this path you know that I
guess you could force the compiler to to
not generate these code regions or cause
them to to force them to abort and do
all your testing on this I don't know if
that would be any worse than so given
that primitive we went ahead and built a
software system on top of it I kind of
want to give you an understanding of
what the system does and I'm going to
use this piece of code as a running
example basically again we did this in
the context of a JVM and I've got two
methods here one called foo that has
this loop in there that's infrequently
taken and it also calls this method bar
which happens to be a synchronized
method in Java and so there's this
monitor entry and monitor exit which
would acquire a lock and release the
lock at the prologue and epilogue to
guarantee the the isolation of the
execution of this code this function
also calls another function as well as
potentially throws an exception which if
the exceptions thrown we have to release
the monitor before we unroll the stack
and whatnot so this is a piece of code
and the first thing our changes to the
compile
have to do if we want to take advantage
of these atomic regions is select the
region that we're gonna do the
optimizations on and so this turns out
to be a bit of an interesting thing by
itself because we want the regions not
to be too small because if they're too
small we don't get a little a lot of
optimization benefit we don't want them
to be too large because if they are they
might overflow the cache and we want to
get good coverage across the whole
execution then we want most of the code
executed to be within atomic regions to
get the benefit of these optimizations
and so we have an algorithm for doing
this but in general what it does is it
it picks the hottest path through
regions of code and tries to estimate
the dynamic instruction length of those
paths which turns out to be a reasonable
proxy for how much optimization
potential it is as well as how much data
they're gonna touch and so it tries to
to size them you know appropriately in
such a way that we get good coverage and
so I'll refer you to the iske paper if
you're interested for the the specific
algorithm but for example it would
probably select both of these methods to
to be within a single region because the
hottest path through this code goes
through this bar method and takes this
particular path it's a cyclic so it's
not going to run very long and then it
takes this path and that's certainly
gonna be small enough to fit within the
cache but might give us some
optimization benefit we might also
inline this into the previous method
also but that didn't fit on the slide so
step two is to identify what's cold and
so for the purposes of the system that
we built we had a static bias that was
anything that's executed less than 1% or
had a bias of less than 1% we'd cut out
so for example this method is executed
less than 1% of the time we reach X also
this back edge from C to B is executed
less than 1% of the time we reach C and
we're also going to cut out any hardware
exceptions because our our our hardware
support for atomic regions doesn't
actually handle exceptions that means
that we don't have to handle the
exceptions in the code that's generated
so that
potential for why to have a hardware
exception is not going to in practice be
a barrier to optimization for us so step
three once we recognize what's cold
we're gonna trim off all that cold stuff
and then we can inline an unroll at this
point and one of the benefits we get
here is that we effectively get partial
inlining and partial unrolling for free
the last step is to take all of these
little pieces that we left hanging and
deal with them by converting them to
assert so for example we're going to
assume assert that X bar is actually
going to go to Y bar and so that shows
up in our code similarly C bar to D bar
also these monitors since we're going to
wrap this whole thing in an atomic
region we don't actually have to handle
the monitors completely so we do some
profiling to say is in fact this monitor
or not access or not contended for in
which case we merely need to check to
see whether the the lock is free and so
this is sort of a software controlled
speculative la collision and what it
does is it both reduces the amount of
single thread overhead that this check
is cheaper than the lock acquire and
release and it also is no longer a
barrier to optimization so we can Optima
move code throughout this block however
we want and then we wrap the whole thing
in an atomic region so we insert the a
region began in a region n nodes and
point them to the the previous flow
graph for foo and so you can see that
we've effectively got this partial
inlining that we've inline in the hot
case and not in the cold case so that
limits the amount of code growth due to
in lining the questions on that
there's some things when you first
described it there were exit conditions
that where you could imagine
implementing the same optimization and
software but restoring from the state on
the hot path to this date on the cold
bath and then it resumes the cold bath
in the right place at least one of these
like the assert monitor is free it's
like you could imagine doing rights
before the place for you well so for
example we have the freedom to you know
I guess it some of it comes from you
know the multi thread safety that we're
free to reorder memory operations two
distinct memory locations you know
independent of the the memory model
because they're gonna appear all in the
same place in the the total memory
ordering put that down here or I could
hoist it up so what extent are we didn't
touch the scheduler so we're very
careful that we don't waste things out
of the region because we had that bug
and caused problems but I don't know to
what extent you know we didn't
specifically try to improve it but now
certainly the the monitor boundaries are
no longer preventing scheduling which
they do in general and Java other
questions so again what I think was one
of the most interesting things that came
out of this piece of work was how easy
it was to implement in the compiler that
it turns out that the support for you
know having this one version of the code
that fails over to the other version of
the code there's already something like
that in the compiler to support
try-catch and so basically we took that
that mechanism and overloaded it we took
the recovery edge for the trycatch and
our recovery edge for our stuff and
mapped it to the exception dispatch edge
in the internal representation so the
control flow is handled already for us
we had it add a new virtual instruction
to the intermediate representation
handle these asserts but it turns out to
be very simple it's basically an add
instruction that doesn't produce a value
so it's a single non control flow
operation in the IR and once we defined
it it turns out that the existing passes
already operate on it because it just
looks like an ad and the partial
redundancy elimination says oh you know
if I have two of them that have the same
inputs and doing the same operation I
can remove one of them and I can
schedule the schedule these freely
throughout the code just as if they were
ads that nobody used the value of but I
can't dead code eliminate them so that
was neat turns out most of the
complexity we add was because of this
region formation and we could do that in
about 2000 lines of code and once we did
that we could take the existing
optimizations without modifying them and
they could find new opportunities for
optimization so again we were surprised
at how easy this was and I claim it's
significantly easier than if you
implement speculative optimizations
without this hardware support so we
evaluated the system this is work we did
in conjunction with Intel so we used the
Apache harmony JVM which is an open
source JVM that Intel was significantly
interested in they were doing a lot of
the development for and we used their
infrastructure for doing full system
execution driven timing simulation so we
we simulate the hardware and did Pentium
4 like microarchitecture again the model
came from the Intel people we use
standard Java benchmarks the Decapolis
suite and one of the challenging pieces
of this work was how do you sample the
execution of a program when the code is
generated dynamically by two separate
compilers and so it's quite a bit of
work to get a methodology that worked
for this but basically we can we insert
in specific Java methods a little marker
and the simulator keeps track of how
many times it's seen that marker go by
and so we can select the same region of
the execution in two runs of the program
assuming the programs largely
deterministic in its execution so it
allows us to do an apples-to-apples
comparison
and what we get from and I say our first
passel implementation of this so you
know again this was you know not a huge
amount of effort went into this compiler
and we're still able to get about a
seventeen percent on average speed up
from this and a fourteen percent
reduction in the number of microbes
executed so again the number of
reduction in micro ops is a relatively
good proxy for reduction in power that
the number of or reduction in dynamic
power at least and so that's the first
point but you can see that the
performance comes from different
benchmarks differently
and in particular I want you to focus on
this case where we get a slowdown
because I know why we get it and I think
we can make it go away the key there is
for that benchmark and a couple of
others we're getting a non-trivial
number of these regions aborting that in
general we like to see you know much
less than 1% of them dying in this case
we're getting on the order of 2% dying
and that's causing a lot of that's
that's causing this slowdown and what
that's due to is that some branches over
time their bias changes so initially
we're profiling the execution and we say
aha we found a branch that's highly
biased and so this is something I want
to optimize but as the execution goes on
the behavior changes and now we're
aborting every time we execute that
region and so this is a relatively easy
thing to do and this is one of the
things we're doing now is building the
system that recognizes when behavior
changes and decides when to reach it the
code and generate a new version based on
this so the other thing that we learned
in doing this
is the compiler is the implications that
has on the hardware the compiler we
built generates atomic regions that are
relatively small
after we've optimized them so you know
we select regions and the optimizations
tend to be relatively effective and so
they get down to tens or hundreds of
instructions and so this has two
implications the first is
that if if it's happening very often
that it has to be fast to take a
checkpoint and it should install the
pipeline and so if it does we if we for
example have to spend 20 cycles taking a
checkpoint that basically gets rid of
all of our potential benefit similarly
these regions are small enough that
multiple of them will fit within the
instruction window of a modern out of
order processor and so the hardware has
to be able to support multiple of these
atomic regions in flight simultaneously
that if I stall at a begin every time
I'm waiting for an end to commit again I
lose all the potential optimization
benefit that we've that we've found in
our studies so in summary atomic
execution makes trivial the
implementation these speculative
optimizations basically we have little
few changes to make to the compiler to
get this benefit and it also simplifies
adding new optimizations like this
partial inlining and partial loop
unrolling it's a minimal to
high-performance hardware implementation
because we're not basically a mentioned
two slides later there's already
multiple companies that have built
Hardware primitives like this the Azul
and the Sun rock have hardware that's
that's somewhat similar to this and we
can get pretty reasonable performance
and reduction in in number instructions
and by adding dynamic feedback we can do
even better question
some of each so it depends a lot by
benchmark you probably want me to
estimate the fraction of which is which
and I would I'd be afraid of doing it so
actually the results that we ran these
results two different ways because we
had this partial inlining benefit we
were concerned that a lot of our benefit
was coming just because we were in
lining more code and so we compared the
base in liner the benefit we got from
the atomic region optimizations versus
the based on the base in lining versus
just in lining a whole lot more and it
turns out that we beat that case by a
little that basically we hugely cranked
up the inlining threshold so that in
line everything it could we still
outperform that and then I think what's
more telling is if we ran the atomic
region optimizations with this this very
aggressive in lining we actually got and
I don't have the data somewhere else the
performance that we got was actually
larger than the sum of the in lining and
the Optima copped ization x' by
themselves that that by having the
aggressive in lining we exposed even
more opportunity for the atomic regions
to get optimization benefit I don't know
if that it all answers your question I I
wish I had off the top of my head
numbers but the thing is they vary a lot
by benchmark there's some benchmarks
where there's a lot of synchronized
methods you know executed and so the
ability to remove that overhead was
significant there's others where that's
totally not important and so trying to
recall in averages is somewhat difficult
Ben did you have a
yes oh this is yeah so this is this is
implemented in the second level so
basically we don't care so much about
the performance of the first level and
we're using that level to get the
profile information necessary to do our
optimization
so the second thing people are willing
that I'll talk about is building hybrid
transactional memory and the goal here
is in my mind getting the best of both
worlds which is we want fast common case
transactions while retaining the ability
to failover to software for things that
the hardware doesn't want to handle and
this is work that we're presenting in
this year's iske so I'm going to assume
does everybody know transactional memory
or heard of it okay so most of you have
probably already recognized that this
notion of atomic execution that I've
been talking about has a lot of
similarities to Hardware transactional
memory and that's part of why we think
that works interesting is because
potentially it allows you to build one
mechanism that can support a lot of
things so again you know so basically
what this atomic execution lets you do
is if I have this atomic statement at my
source level I can just translate it
directly to you know a transaction begin
a load in a store in a transaction end
and just by holding shared coherence
permission for things that I read and
exclusive coherence permission for
things that I'm writing if I can hold
those until I commit then I can commit
my transaction so this is again
relatively simple to implement and this
is what Azul and Sun have implemented
the problem why it's not the end of
story for transactional memory among
other things is the limitations that
it's limited to the size of the hardware
structure that we're going to allow to
do this can't support context switching
and perhaps it doesn't some more support
all of the semantics that you might want
from a transactional memory programming
model there's a number of hardware
transactional memory proposals that try
to go beyond this original this simple
Hardware transactional memory sort of
Herlihy and maus interface but they get
kind of nasty and given that architects
to date have been you know unwilling to
even give double compare and swap to
this point the fact that they're the
thought that they're willing to
guarantee forward progress for arbitrary
sized transactions and very long running
and worrying about you know you know
operating system virtual machine running
underneath you you know dealing with
page
whatnot I'm not optimistic that they're
going to give everything and so so I'm
not sure all this is gonna happen
anytime soon or at all so the
alternative to the Harvard transsexual
memories is software transactional
memories which again I'm going to
largely assume people know about is that
a fair assumption so I'm gonna I'm gonna
talk about a little just because this
I'm going to talk about the one that we
use in our work in particular and we can
argue about that but basically the idea
is we want to do conflict detection and
handle rollback in software the rollback
we can handle by right logging that
before we overwrite a value we record
the old version so this is an eager
update STM that I'm assuming and do
conflict detection if assuming a word
based STM by maintaining an ownership
table and so if we want to access a
variable within a software transaction
we can take its address hash it to some
location in this ownership table check
for conflicts and then attain ownership
to that line so the key thing about
software transactions is they don't have
the virtualization problems that
hardware transactions do you can have
very large ones they can run very long
they can do i oh you can do crazy you
know nesting models and whatnot you know
they have all the flexibility of
software the problem is they have all
the overhead of software to potentially
so when you translate this atomic
statement typically you might have to
save some state at the beginning of the
transaction maybe registers maybe not
and then before the first access to any
piece of memory you have to add a read
barrier if it's a read or in a write
barrier if it's a write and these are
gonna do these lookups on the the the
metadata and potentially write state as
well as do logging if necessary and then
when we end the transaction we have to
walk our logs and go and release
ownership to these various things so the
key is that all of this cost something
and so that adds overhead to the
transactions and also it makes it you
know undesirable to do all of this for
for the non transactional code and so
typically you get
what you might call weak atomicity in
that you don't detect conflicts between
non-transactional code and transactional
code so there was a neat idea which was
this notion of hybrid transactional
memory that says let's try to get the
best of both worlds let's try to get
Hardware performance and software
virtualized ability by running small
transactions in Hardware hopefully
that's the common case and then running
things that don't fit in the hardware
and software and hopefully that's
uncommon but we can still make forward
progress this is a great idea except
there's one challenge which is detecting
the interactions between the hardware
transactional memory and the software
transactional memory so between the
hardware transactions we can detect
conflicts using the coherence protocol
we detect conflicts between the software
transactions using the ownership table
software transactions can't break the
isolation of hardware transactions
that's not in a case we have to worry
about because again the hardware
transactions are strongly atomic and so
if a software transaction tries to
access something that's part of a
hardware transaction it'll break inside
a miss city and force the hardware
transaction to rollback the key problem
is keeping the harver transactions from
breaking the isolation of the software
transactions specifically you know
making sure that a hardware transaction
doesn't read some stale data software
transaction or that the software
transaction doesn't read a value before
and after a hardware transaction is
committed a new value and so the the
solution that the original hybrid
transactional memory proposed was to
have the hardware transactions snoop the
ownership table and so what this entails
is adding read barriers of a sort and
write barriers to the hardware
transactional memory version and the
drawbacks of this approach are twofold
one is although the hardware transaction
gives us transactional memory gives a
strong an Amissah T the atomicity of the
whole system even though most of our
transactions might execute in the
hardware we can't assume anything you
know we can only assume we can Amissah T
for the whole system more importantly
we've added this overhead to our common
case which is exactly what we didn't
want to do so this is what we're going
to try to address and get zero overhead
common
case transactions and the way I'm going
to do that is by adding fine-grain
hardware memory protection to the list
of available Hardware primitives to our
system so I'm assuming a heart low
overhead fine-grained memory protection
mechanism and what this means is by
memory protection I'm assuming much like
virtual memory page protection what
we're getting is the ability to get
notified before we access a protected
piece of memory so and that memory
protection should not just span what's
in the cache but should span potentially
out to disk it's fine grain in that we
want to protect granularity smaller than
a page and for our application at a
granularity cache block suffice is
because that's the granularity that the
hardware transactional memory is going
to be running it anyway and it should be
low overhead especially we want very low
overhead checking of these permissions
and relatively low overhead of
registering and D registering
protections and so the design decision
we've made in this case is that it
should be user mode to set these
privileges and so we avoid any you know
system overhead of doing a sis call to
do that but that means it's effectively
a cooperative mechanism that it's not
useful for security purposes but I'm
somewhat agnostic about this design
decision but the point is you know what
I'm interested in this work is
demonstrating what you can do with this
fine-grained memory protection to do
that work we had to assume one
particular implementation to study but
I'm again agnostic on the particular
implementation but what we use is a
design called UFO or what we call UFO
which is an acronym for user fault on
read and user fault on write so what we
assume there is that we can steal a
couple bits from ECC by Rhian coding ACC
at a larger granularity and so we free
up two bits per cache line and those two
bits we have a fault on raid and a fault
on write bit these live with the cache
so whenever the data gets moved around
the system these bits go with it
we keep them coherent by allowing them
only to be written when you have
exclusive permission for that line so
only when I know I have the only copy
this block can I actually change these
bits and then when other people
requested they're guaranteed to get the
same value as everybody else so again
these bits move through between caches
as well as into memory and we store this
data in ECC in main memory in addition
we can page those bits out by we've made
small changes to Linux so that when it
pages things out it goes and harvests
those bits stores them on the side and
when it brings the data back in it puts
them back and this adds negligible
overhead except in the case when you're
already hugely thrashing memory and this
is the least of your problems in that
case and so what happens is we access
data normally as we're accessing data we
read these bits also and then at retire
time if we're accessing a piece of data
that has one of these bits set and we're
accessing it in a way that conflicts
with that we get an exception at retire
time and that invokes a user handler and
so we can then do whatever we want at
that point in software so that's the
primitive we built a software system on
top of that so what we did is we added
UFO support into the STM to make the STM
strongly atomic and so what we did is
that transactions set these UFO bits
when they acquire ownership so when in
these read barriers for example it'll
set the fault on write bit for the block
that it's reading and in a write barrier
it'll set both the fault on read and
fault on write bits and so what that
gives us is that non-transactional
accesses that would otherwise break the
atomicity of the software transaction
get prevented from completing does that
make sense
so thereby we get strong anima city and
to avoid getting spurious UFO faults
from an SDM transaction the FCM
transaction turns off the fault so that
it you know it's protected its own data
but we don't want to get faults when
it's accessing its own data and it
conflicts between software transactions
are already going to be detected by the
ownership table so a key is that these
UFO bits don't introduce limitations on
the STM in terms of its virtualize
ability for example in
they're persistent that we have them for
all of memory so that's not going to
limit the transaction size and they're
also not part of the core and so we can
context switch without problems
so in this implementation to make the
implementation somewhat simple we've
implemented our ownership table at a
cache block granularity and so that
means we just need to set and clear
these bits whenever we create an entry
in our ownership table and set that's
when we set a bit and we clear a bit
whenever we remove an entry in the
ownership table and so one key that for
anybody who's familiar with STM's this
effectively requires us to do visible
readers there's no other software
maintenance beyond the ownership table
so that's all we need to do to keep
track of when to set and clear the bits
and this means that there's negligible
overhead beyond our baseline STM and so
that's just what this graph shows is the
black is our STM without UFO support and
the gray is the STM with UFO support and
you can see there's not much difference
but the STM does have a certain overhead
to begin with again that's why we have
the hybrid transactional memory so in
particular I'm you know it's nice that
it's negligible overhead but I'm really
not that concerned about the overhead to
the STM because my goal is to get most
of the transactions executing and
hardware to begin with that the STM is
sort of hopefully the last best hope
question so I need to set the bits
whenever I need to set the fault on
write bit whenever I'm reading and I
need to know when to clear that bit and
so I need to know when I'm the last
reader leaving does that make sense
that would be sufficient for knowing
when to clear the bits knowing who they
are is necessary if you want to do
contention management but that's sort of
a standard STM issue
question so what you adding these UFO
bits does is it enables our hardware
transactions to avoid these read
barriers and the reason why is because
the with the STM being strongly atomic
that if the hardware transaction tries
to access something that the software
transactions accessing it'll receive
this fault and prevent it from breaking
the software transactions atomicity so
this is our our main goal is that again
we get back to this uninstrumented
hardware transaction that can run at
full speed that makes sense
so there's one potential caveat those of
you that are paying attention setting
the UFO bits requites requires write
permission even if the STM is only
reading so that means we potentially
have false conflicts with a hardware
transaction that I can have two
transactions just reading a line and the
hardware transaction has shared
permission for it the software
transaction when it's setting the bit
has to acquire exclusive permission and
so it has to invalidate the hardware
transaction it turns out we were worried
about this we were all prepared to solve
this problem and the problem never
showed up at least in our workloads so
we've done some sensitivity analysis to
say what if we could magically set these
bits without acquiring permission and
everything got 1% faster but we decided
1% was fine price to pay for not having
to change the coherence protocol or do
something nasty I think in practice
there's software solutions that would
potentially solve this if it was a
problem that my guess is this would
largely be a problem on widely shared
data which was infrequently written in
which case you could set the bit the
first time and then lazily clear it when
you actually had somebody that wanted to
write it so that the last reader doesn't
actually clear the bit when it leaves
because the conflict only occurs when
you set or clear the bit when you
to write the bit that we can have as
many software transactions reading this
as long as we don't transition from
having zero software transactions to
having one or more software transactions
I don't know if that makes sense but I
think that's also the main reason why it
turns out not to be a problem in our
workloads so again we evaluated the
system we built a library based STM
currently it's very blocking and that's
not so good if we actually had threads
swapping and whatnot but it was easier
to build at the moment we're trying to
resolve that by can AskMe offline if
you're interested it's performance is
pretty similar to TL 2 which is a
contemporary STM we also built a
simulation of the hardware this is our
own full system multiprocessor simulate
timing simulator again we use processor
parameters that are representative of
modern processors we use the stamp
transactional benchmarks doing full
benchmark runs because they're
relatively short programs and we compare
to an ideal HTM so this is what if we
could do everything in hardware and
still have you know arbitrarily try size
arbitrarily sized transactions and still
be able to rollback an aborted
transaction in a single cycle so this is
kind of an ideal upper bound probably
unrealistic upper bound as well as two
previously proposed hybrid transactional
memories so the one that I mentioned
here and then phase TM phase TM says
we'll solve that problem by allowing
only Hardware transactions or only
software transactions at any time so the
the I'm not going to show you all the
data I'm going to show you I think the
most interesting part of the data is the
case where we actually have some
transactions over flow so the the key
points of pieces of data are that this
our UFO hybrid this gray triangle
performs almost identically to the
unbounded in almost all the cases so in
this case it's pretty much identical in
this case it's pretty much identical and
only in this case
case where there's a non-trivial number
of transactions that have to execute in
software do we get much of a divergence
and basically this is almost as good as
we could do because fundamentally if you
have transactions executing software and
there's an overhead from executing
transactions and software you know
that's going to cause you to lose some
performance the key is that it's robust
that and you can't really see this from
this graph but the the fact that some
transactions are running in software
isn't preventing the other transactions
from running in hardware or or harming
them the other hybrids however even when
things don't failover into software for
example the hybrid TM scheme has some
overhead that's causing it to perform
somewhere between the software
transactional memories and the hardware
transactional memories and in particular
for phase TM when there are a
non-trivial number of transactions
failing over to software that causes all
of the transactions to fail over to
software in the regions where there's at
least one transaction failing over to
software so you actually see this this
point where you actually the performance
goes down as you execute have more
threads executing because you're more
likely at any given time to have one
transaction that has to execute in
software which hurts everybody else
their questions on that so I am pretty
pleased with these results but I think
what's arguably more interesting is what
we need from the primitive in order to
get this to work one the first lesson we
learned was that good contention between
hardware transit contention management
between Hardware transactions is
fundamental so in our scheme we used age
ordering we're eventually settled on
using age ordering because we first
tried requestor wins and this is what I
believe is rule and rock or both
implementing which is much simpler
it basically says if I you know I have
my transactional working set and if you
come along and request something that I
want that I have I give it to you and I
kill myself so the requester wins the
problem with that is you have potential
for live lock and also just you know a
lot less forward progress is
being made and so it's potentially it's
it's guaranteed to be more complex to
support some sort of better contention
management policy and hardware but what
our results suggest is that gives you
about a factor of two in performance and
so it's probably worth doing and so I
have some ideas how we could do this we
we implemented this somewhat magically
in our simulations but we think we have
a way of doing this that's not so bad
the second thing is that it's important
never to failover to software if you can
it all avoid it in particular you don't
want to failover to software due to
conflicts and the reason why is if
you're failing transactions the software
because of contention you're only going
to aggravate the contention and so
that's less of an effect but still so
basically this is saying oh if I fail
five times I'm going to failover to
software and so we picked this because
this was the policy that the hybrid
transactional memory used because they
had to do this to make forward progress
because with the requester wins
otherwise they had live lock and their
applications never ended but it's
important you know if you can avoid
doing this that'll save you ten percent
of the time the key is you need to know
when it's necessary to failover to
software and when it might not be
necessary and so the key to doing this
is having a piece of code between when
you try it in saw in hardware and you
failover to software to decide should I
try this at hardware again or should I
fall through to software and so again
this comes back to the point we had
before you need to know why you failed
that if you failed because of overflow
or i/o or system calls or some
application exception like you divide by
zero it's very unlikely you're gonna
succeed if you retry in hardware in
contrast if you fail due to a conflict
or an interrupt it's very likely that
you're gonna succeed if you retry and
hardware especially if you have some
sort of back-off implemented to reduce
the contention finally if you have some
sort of system exception like a page
fault you're likely to succeed if you
retry in hardware if you first do some
work so for example if you bring the
page into memory and then retry in
hardware you're likely to succeed and so
the hardware we settled on records when
it aborts the
for treason it also counts the conflict
so that we can do we can decide when to
do back off that if we get one conflict
we might want to not want to bother with
backup but if this is our our fifth
conflict since we committed a
transaction we might want to do some
back off that's a function of how many
conflicts we've had and also records the
kind of system exception happen and
address so that we can poke that piece
of memory bring it into memory and retry
the transaction in hardware so assuming
there's no questions and feel free to
ask questions what having the software
transactional memory plus UFO plus these
atomic regions gives us is the ability
to do full-speed common case
transactions have strong atomicity for
all transactions we still have the
ability to fall back to software to
handle you know arbitrary sized
transactions and context switches and it
also and this is something that we're
playing with now is allows us to evolve
the semantics of the transactional
memory so in particular one thing that
that we've been playing with is trying
to implement this kind of retry
primitive where I wait on a bunch of
things using the transactional memory
system and so we have an implementation
that runs in the STM and by being a
little smarter about the hardware by
allowing the hardware to to receive the
the UFO fault and not destroy its
atomicity we can actually get Hardware
transactions that can wake up software
transactions without aborting themselves
so that's something that we're playing
with now but in general you know what
we'd like to believe part of reason why
we're doing this work is that that this
structure allows us to evolve the
semantics of the STM without having to
change the specific implementation of
the hardware and one point is that it's
that this whole thing is built from
hardware primitives that are useful
beyond @tm that in particularly atomic
regions are useful you know both for
doing speculative law collision as well
as the compiler optimizations and
hardware fine grained memory protection
I think has a lot of uses including you
know scalable watchpoints
well as concurrent garbage collection
applications check ensuring invariants
for other speculative optimizations
things like that so I think it's you
know it's potentially a very costly
primitive for the hardware to provide
but I think if it does provide it
there's a lot of software systems that
can use it so you go to the hardware
people and they say oh yeah you want two
of those ECC bits so does everybody else
and so the key I think is and this is
you know one of the things that that we
have for future work is figuring out how
we can expose those bits so that lots of
people can use them simultaneously so
effectively virtualize them and use them
for multiple purposes simultaneously
without causing the whole system to bog
down so that's one of the reasons why
you know so effectively we're assuming
that you know in the future all machines
are going to run with ECC so we can
steal these bits because if we if they
aren't then we can't the other thing is
and this is a little subtle that if
you're not running with sequential
consistency there's a little bit of a
challenge which most hardware isn't that
you need to be able to look at the bit
before you commit the store to the line
and often you commit a store without
actually having the line and so you need
the ability to commit a store and say oh
I shouldn't have done that and roll that
back but it turns out that has a lot of
similarities to the hardware support you
need for doing atomic execution and so
we believe you can overload those same
mechanisms to give you the ability to
you know be able to do stores and then
undo them so we there's some nastiness
there but I think the I think if you
just you know go to the hardware people
say look you know here's this
application they'll say it's too
expensive for what you want but
you know why do I think it is I'm not
claiming that it is I'm saying so again
this is one particular implementation
for fine grain memory protection there
are others I'm not claiming that it
isn't you know half the people I talked
to say that it you know it might hit you
know there's some point where you know
it becomes it makes sense that as
transistors get smaller and smaller
eventually it's going to happen I don't
know when that time is some people say
that is in the next five years other
people say it isn't I'm not an expert
enough to say one way or the other so
that was one question what was the other
question somewhere you know so ECC
memory already exists right and the
question is and you know this this trick
is well-known as sort of how you can
rien code ECC that the the dec alpha 21
364 did this trick to store its
directories in memory the trick is you
know that there's a lot of people you
know who would love to have these bits
for various you know security whatnot
and so so far they're not you know
they're not there but you know there's a
long list of things that you know you
could use them for and so how do you
decide which bits to allocate to whom is
a challenge it's a scarce resource so
you know but I think the you know
especially if we if people are going to
continue programming concurrent programs
with you know the current race full
programming models having some bits to
track accesses the memory will be useful
for building tools for you know race
detection and whatnot debugging in
context of country I think there's a lot
of neat applications if you expose some
of these bits to the programmer
and so the key is is exposing them in a
way such that it's not like you can use
them for this or this at any given time
because we're gonna want to run lots of
tools simultaneously potentially or
tools or system services so the last
thing I talk about and it's relatively
brief is hardware support for software
instrumentation so basically how we can
get arbitrary program profiling almost
for free and this is work that we had in
C geo which we presented last week but
the neat thing is based on preprints of
this two companies have also already
told me that they're planning features
and new processors that were inspired by
this so it's pretty cool so the gist is
that increasingly people are building
software systems that want to monitor
themselves for some reason or another
and so one common way that gets done is
by instrumentation so for example Google
in their search engine in their deployed
search engine that you use collects two
kind at least two kinds of information
one is the size of heap allocated
objects and they log this so they can
and also the allocation site so they can
figure out where they're allocating
memory and periodically when they get
lock contention they pull a whole stack
trace and they log this and this is used
information that they use to do
performance analysis on their deployed
software the the thing is these are too
expensive to collect all the time so
what tip people typically do is sampling
so they have their instrumentation code
and they wrap it in the sampling
framework where I decrement the counter
every time I come by this site and when
it hits zero I collect the information
and reset the counter so this is great
because it allows us to take the cost of
this instrumentation and scale it as a
function of sampling rate so just by
cranking down the sampling rate I can
reduce the amount of time I spend doing
this instrumentation and sampling works
very well on programs because they tend
to do the same things over and over
again the problem though
the framework has an overhead itself and
that framework overhead is a fixed cost
it doesn't scale with the sampling rate
and so thinking at a hardware cough
hardware software co.design approach
clearly this instrumentation isn't the
problem because we can address that by
the sampling rate it's the framework
that's the the problem so what we
proposed is a new hardware primitive an
instruction called branch on random so
this is a conditional branch except that
rather than specifying the condition for
the branch I specify the frequency that
I want the branch to be taken so the
frequency in our implementation is four
bits so a value from zero to fifteen and
the actual probability of the branch
being taken is one-half to that
frequency power so we get a range of
probabilities from the branch region
taken 100% of the time to 0.003 percent
of the time and the key thing is that
each branch can have its own frequency
so we can have lots of these sprinkle
throughout the code and they can all
have their own frequency and the key is
this instruction gets a lot less
overhead than this sampling framework
because first of all it's a single
instruction it doesn't use registers it
doesn't access memory it doesn't do
arithmetic and we can resolve the branch
early in the pipeline and the key is how
we generate these probabilities and it
turns out there's a very simple hardware
pseudo-random number generator called a
linear feedback shift register so
basically I have a bunch of bits worth
of register and from this you know and I
shift them over every time I access it
and I shift in a new value which is an
XOR of various other bits that's not
particularly important what is important
is give me n bits of this register and
it's sequences through all possible
values for those n bits except for all
zeros so if you give me enough bits the
expected value of any bit is one 50% of
the time and so if I want to get a
branch on random that's taken one out of
every 16 times I just and together four
of these bits and that gives me a signal
that's one 1/16 of the time and then I
shift over the register
and again I have an expected value of
getting a 1 1/16 of the time-independent
of the state of the lfsr
so at decode I extract the frequency
from the the instruction and I select
the an gate that has the right number of
inputs to tell me whether I'm taken and
the other neat thing is we can just
never tell the branch predictors about
this instruction and so it's by default
always predicted not taken so it's
correctly predicted without any hardware
resources all the time except for the
one out of n times that I want the
branch taken so the result of this is
compared to a software framework which
hits one asymptote of performance as we
scale the sampling interval the branch
on random hits a much lower asymptote
and we've done these experiments the
number of different ways and what we
find is that in practice we get about a
factor of 10 reduction in the overhead
of the sampling framework and so what
that tells me or what that seems like an
opportunity for me is that I can
sprinkle these throughout my code and
collect the information that I want to
collect with very little overhead and
for those of you aware of the Arnold
Reiter framework for doing
instrumentation we find that this effect
is multiplicative with that effect so if
you also do Arnold writer using the
branch on randoms to implement the
Arnold Rider framework you get a factor
of 10 over what you would have gotten
with just Arnold Rider by itself so
that's pretty cool so I can stop here or
I can do three slides of where I'm going
so three slides so what I want to do
with the speculative compiler
optimizations to sort of push the push
the aggressiveness of optimization so
this really nice paper out of IBM by
Nick Mitchell and Gary Savitsky about
bloat in framework urn applications that
use a lot of framework so they they work
with these financial customers that are
busy slapping code together as fast as
they can and they find that the
framework built on top of framework on
top of framework to the point where just
to extract a few bytes from a soap
message in order to populate a Java date
field it takes 268 call
and 70 objects to to do that
transformation and so the scope of this
you know so that's a huge inefficiency
to this it's a huge efficiency for the
programmer because they only had to
write two lines of code but execution
wise it's a huge inefficiency but it's
such an efficient it's such a scope that
the compiler just can't wrap its head
around it and so what our hope is that
by being able to focus on the small set
of paths in this code that are actually
getting executed in practice we can
bring that into scope realize what's
actually going on not really realize but
but say the state value is being moved
from this object to this object to this
object why don't we just skip all that
and move here and these are the
conditions that have to hold that that
enable this transformation and encode
that as an atomic region with these
asserts verifying that those conditions
hold so we'd like to try to eliminate
some of that bloat the second thing is
this thing I talked about earlier sort
of trying to virtualize this UFO
fine-grained memory protection so that
it's it's useful for multiple
applications and again the key challenge
is knowing way it's safe to clear those
bits and so one of the things that we're
playing with right now is trying to
peripera virtualize this so that things
that use those bits don't set them or
and clear them directly they go through
a software API which decides when to set
and clear those bits and then finally
many of you probably know that Intel and
Microsoft recently started this
Universal parallelism Research Center at
UIUC along with the one at Berkeley and
one of the emphasis of our Center is
deterministic languages that one of the
beliefs is that what one of the things
that makes writing explicitly parallel
code in the context of shared memory is
the possibility for races and so one of
the big activities is developing
deterministic paralleling languages that
can flag potential races at compile time
and this offers us Hardware people new
opportunities to to support these kinds
of languages
for trying to relax the synchronization
that is introduced to avoid these races
for increased concurrency at runtime as
well as to exploit the knowledge in the
security to optimize data movement to
reduce you know latency for data
accesses so one of the activities I'll
be playing in the center is supporting
the deterministic language development
through hardware mechanisms so that is
what I have to say and I'm happy to take
any further questions
yep well there a grinning groups of
instrumentation and making the decision
once we're making the process of making
that decision cheaper so it's almost
cost lists so you know I that it's a
perfectly fine conclusion it turns so
you know so you know if Arnold Rider
gives you a factor of three benefit you
know we get you know we reduce our
little sliver you know to one third of
it was you might say that's negligible
and not bother with the Arnold Rider
that's a fine conclusion from my
standpoint but they are they still tend
to be a multiplicative in our
experiments answer that we are the
writer is a moderately complicated JIT
compilation technique whereas what
you're proposing could be used by random
C programmers benefit but your
conclusion is of saying that may be what
does he thought long it's not necessary
to do the other ones getting random fun
writer I'm not gonna argue with also but
that's a value judgment not a scientific
statement there's various profiling
mechanisms that count down
performance counters and taking usually
a trap to something and reset it to some
value could you get the same effect by
having special-purpose performance
counters so the problem with the
performance counters is that you know in
general so I view the branch on random
and instrumentation in general as a nice
complement to what performance counters
give you that the performance counters
are very useful for collecting low-level
information of you know I was here
I missed in the cache I got a branch
misprediction those kinds of things very
low level whereas instrumentation is
much better doing higher level stuff
including value profiling like oh I
called this function this went for this
indirect call it was this specific
function that I called you know like in
the two things that I mentioned the so
really I sort of see them as hitting
different things you could have you know
you could emulate what we're doing in
effect by I receive a random sample and
I do a lookup in a lookup table and if
I'm at this particular PC I collect the
size of the heap allocation and where I
was but I don't really know of anybody
who's doing that and it's kind of a pain
again sort of what you said that the
mechanism is clean enough that you know
I could add a if 1% statement to my
language and boom you know code generate
it directly so I need a lot less runtime
support to do that and so what I find in
practice is that there's a lot of people
that even though hardware counters would
have solved their problem better they
didn't use them because it was much
simpler just to deploy the
instrumentation yeah yeah so
self-modifying code + blanch on random
gives you adaptive Sam yeah yeah so
that's all right but yeah so you can
start with 100% get the first sample
maybe collect a couple samples and then
shift it to 50% you know such and so
forth so yeah so you can get guaranteed
sampling you know
so that yeah it's definitely something
we've thought of we haven't implemented
but sort of you know it makes sense so
it should work right can you think that
hablar con I just think the for east
beats so the the thing about that so the
the property we get from the lfsr is
what gives us this that each branch can
have its own frequency and their
independence so the the if I just have a
counter and I have to you know that if
if it's a counter and I'm the only
branch on random in the code I will
always get the nth sample if I have
another you can think if there was a
loop and I had to to branch on randoms
in the loop I would get you know a
sample every n over two and the other
guy wouldn't get any perhaps that
there's some interference between the
that if you implement it as a counter
rather than an lfsr you tend to get
interference between multiple branch on
random sites that you don't get with the
lfsr I don't know if that makes sense
the other thing you get for free is that
I actually can show you this so we did
some accuracy numbers also let me go
ahead and close this one of the things
that's is this the right one
no it must be it doesn't look right yeah
I think this cements so in one of the
benchmarks we had that there was if you
used a counter there was something in
the the program that happened at that
you know same power of two kind of
frequency and so there was this resonant
sort of between the program behavior and
the sampling rate and the thing about
the lfsr is even though I'm sampling one
out of every 16 times for example it's
not every 16th time and so the
likelihood that I get some resonance is
a lot smaller there's still a chance
because it is a probabilistic see it's a
deterministic sequence but it's a very
small likelihood so I think there's
really no reason not to use an lfsr over
a counter because it gives better
properties and it's no more expensive
it's actually potentially cheaper